welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i'm mark bernard
three hey 300 time kids 300th time
episode 300. this is
fat man and then we kick someone in a
well
welcome kids on a sunday evening on the
east coast sunday afternoon
brunch edition batman beyond brunch
yes we're having a siesta podcast um
this is a special day ladies and
gentlemen a special day
calls for a special sponsor that's right
indeed uh the good
you see this this is a [ __ ] party
right here
they're not the sponsor they're not the
sponsors but you know who brought it to
us
the good folks at door dash yes they did
that's right you could order food you
could order whatever you want
to eat put in your body in a good way
positive way
and they'll bring you booze if you if
you want to celebrate if you're having a
celebration [ __ ]
call doordash they'll bring you the
go-go juice uh doordash
allows you to order food right to your
door
from any number of ten thousand or more
restaurants
uh that will bring the food to you put
it at your doorstep
not even talk to you because we live in
a [ __ ] completely asocial world
indeed i mean if you have erected a nice
plexiglass barrier between you and the
outside world
got one of these roll it like a bank
just be like did you see lindsey graham
was the guy's name was sharon
oh yeah jamie harrison he brought one of
these
into his debate where he's like i don't
know where you've been dude
and he put one of these up hold on are
you one of them spreader republicans
just hanging out having coveted partying
all that says to me is what's his name
jamie harrison yep
vote him because this guy watches fat
man beyond
he saw a good idea and he took it into
his own work man i respect that he's
like [ __ ] chris hemsworth remember
chris hemsworth listen to the podcast
and then thor ragnarok got better i
heard on the kevin smith ball guys we
were making [ __ ] movies
the best christmas worth you'll ever
hear i don't know what that was
um doordash though ladies and gentlemen
let me tell you what they got
right now our listeners get five
dollars off of their order and if you
order something for ten bucks
five of that's coming off and zero
delivery fees
that's the important part yes for the
first order of fifteen dollars or more
oh so i was wrong about the ten a little
bit i was gonna correct you but then i
figured you'd get there you know what a
good friend he let me hang out there and
he's like he'll get to it
he's reading i know how reading works
he's gonna hit the next sentence things
will be a lot more clear
when you download the doordash app and
you enter the code very important fat
man
all one word look this is easily going
to be a two-hour show so if i'm you
go to doordash right now while we're
sitting here talking do i want sushi
do i want uh indian food would i like
some chinese what do i want to watch
these guys too
what's going to feel good in my tum tum
is these dudes like [ __ ] tell me all
the [ __ ] that's coming in the future
maybe we have special guests we don't
have any but you don't know yet could be
anything
doordash should have like a food
sommelier who can tell you what
pairs well with what you're watching oh
my god could you imagine like i'm
watching a podcast he's like oh well
that's more about the ears close your
eyes
and have a nice helping of hummus from
you don't want a loud food you want a
soft food start crunching a lot while
you're watching it so yes maybe a nice
i don't know soup gazpacho perhaps
ceviche i don't know
i think my friend is on to something
doordash we need a doordash sommelier
and he's volunteering i'm just saying
could you imagine you could do that from
home too
yeah but you'd have to be on call all
the time so even if we're doing the show
it'd be like
and you've got to be like hold on hello
jessica edwards
yes what are you doing oh you're
watching that
[ __ ] charlize thera movie on netflix
that our buddy did
uh hmm all right greek food i think
she's a she was a legendarily greek uh
heroine or kfc pair as well with
everything i got a show to dubai
i like that suddenly i'm the movie phone
guy
hello and welcome to sommelier chat
sooner or later i'm like look mark can't
do the show anymore because as you can
see
a good idea is a good idea but let's
take it over yeah uh episode 301
and we're done because he's just all the
[ __ ] time on the app 301 and done
um listen listen kids doordash is
waiting for you right now and you're
gonna get five bucks off of the order
don't forget that code is fat man all
one word
for five dollars off your first order
with doordash that's the app
that brings you to food you're hungry
you want food you want it to be good
they'll bring it to you
no more rhyming i mean no i ran out of
rhymes anybody want a peanut doordash
will bring you that peanut
ordering is so [ __ ] easy man you open
the doordash app listen to these
instructions
you choose what you want to eat tell
them what to do self-explanatory
uh and you can and your your food will
be left safely outside your door with
the new contactless delivery
drop-off setting 300 000 partners dude
in the us puerto rico
canada and australia wow we've got
people watching all over the [ __ ]
globe yeah
you can support your logo go to's or
choose from your favorite
national restaurants like chipotle
is that how you say it chipotle thank
you there we go wendy's
when wise is that how you say it or
cheese quake
in fact yes cheesecake factory could you
imagine you're like
i can order from 300 000 places let me
get some cheesecake
[Laughter]
sometimes you do i've done it i
appreciate the exit 123 and the garden
state parkway reference
cheese quake cheese quick you can pick
that up the [ __ ] yeah
that's jersey right there if you know
back home cheese quake is where you go
to
get some gas uh do a person exchange
like i'm dropping off your niece and i
gotta [ __ ] meet you halfway
cheesecake
or get rid of a body because they've got
some weeds there as well
nothing good happens in genes catch a
pack as the christopher montesante was
living off
of you've probably seen it many times in
the sopranos
christopher and that's what we think of
when we think of door dash
cheese quake cheese quake tastes good
um what are you waiting for man like if
tonight's the night
you want to celebrate 300 episodes of
fat man beyond
door dash it right now you get yourself
some door dash
and you're doing us a solid door dash is
like hey look at that it went up
during their time what's your name
that's a door dash to us what would you
like
what a [ __ ] good more liquor because
it's a party
um ah you know what we'll do that off
camera we'll have uh jc
orders there you go doordash that's
[ __ ] smart see
we got two hours here then it'll be like
that's what we did with your ad money we
bought [ __ ] food to beat ourselves
uh yeah we're ordering some doordash
we're telling you to do it yeah
just come to the the closed bar on
hollywood boulevard yeah george edge
like
is this yeah go down the alley when you
see the pile of human [ __ ]
knock on that door is that what that is
is that what we saw outside jaycees
can't be a dog right
no yeah that log was [ __ ] huge and
did you see the big [ __ ] like
hornet's nest of flies just oh i was
fighting them to get into the door
and then they're like why would we go in
there we got everything we need right
here we door dashed in some [ __ ]
yes those [ __ ] ordered right to the
door they left it there
contactless we'll have them deliver our
[ __ ] to the front door
yes please and our [ __ ] will be edible
by more than flies because doordash has
300 000
edible restaurant partners all over the
u.s puerto rico
australia and another place as well
canada how can we forget them
door dash there's only two [ __ ] d's
in this world that matter
doordash ladies and gentlemen they are
the proud sponsor
of fat man beyond episode 300. indeed
give them your love huzzah all right we
done i think so
this is how you begin a party man my
first uh bud light seltzer not a sponsor
but boy they better jump on board soon
otherwise we're gonna have a problem
last time i have one of these i had a
good time
i remember you you're working a [ __ ]
guinness i'm watching the [ __ ] kids
we're celebrating
that's true man or irish style indeed uh
here we go
what are they solange no whether it's
slanted slanted get slammed
cheers oh my god that doesn't taste like
alcohol at all
i think i'll have nine more cells this
did
i'm gonna sip that like a soup
if i was any kind of man i'd have
punctured a hole
shotgun yes shotguned it for show 300.
maybe we'll do that with the mango the
least manly drink in the world i have a
[ __ ] shotgun
look at that [ __ ] they're like did you
just shotgun a hard
seltzer yes i did yes i'm all man
um 300 man what uh
mark uh what what is your take on the
journey thus far
i have been podcasting for quite some
time i think it's
in february of last year well in
february of this year it's going to be
14 years wow you joined the podcasting
uh journey particularly this one for fat
man beyond about when do you remember
uh this would have been to uh
what art wasn't it not it would have to
be
no yeah no yeah it was like 13 because i
had moved out here by then
that and that made it possible to go on
the record oh [ __ ]
i don't know jc check out the wikipedia
page and see when it started when mark
jumped on and stuff
now uh you have this was my first
regular podcasting gig
before anything else before anything
like my first podcast appearance ever
was on plus one
with you and the morning show the
morning show because i was in la
um for a stretch on the first season of
vlogs we used to use sir
smodcast internet radio we did the
morning shows yeah
and uh and so i hopped on that some some
like 8 a.m some morning like come to the
house we're doing a podcast come be a
guest
okay sure and then like a year later i
think i had moved out there a year and a
half
and then we did fat man and then we did
batman on batman we did the uh
the commentary tracks we did the dark
night returns
and then we kept doing and then we
started doing like the
version with jc remember we shot it at
right greg's place well first we shot it
at your place we just put cameras up
in your office we put a couple gopros up
at the office yeah which office
your house in before we went to greg's
yeah we did it in your office we had
like a little
the little desk cameras and then we went
then you guys i think we did defy
in beverly hills yeah and this show's
been around
man and then we bumped around we did it
at greg's
and then we moved back to the living
room and then we moved
here in september 2017.
wow so we've been here for three years
this has been the home of fat man beyond
right here the scum and villainy
yeah so we were wandering in the wild
for a while looking for a place to call
home
this is where it became and when did we
become fat man
beyond that was after the heart attack
right and i lost weight i was like we
can't really call it fat man on batman
anymore yeah we
let's leave the fat man felt kind of
like paul's advertising looks like the
first episode was june 1st 2012
of fat man i'm back batman on batman
period
wow so the show is like over eight years
old and now we're
episode 300. but mark you've been around
for a minute i started what are the big
differences
um i started in like episode 70
something maybe yes
um i mean i think the big differences
are the initial iteration of the podcast
was
you and a guest talking specifically
about batman yeah for a good long while
um you know rotating guests and some
more than one episode and you know
occasionally there would just be like a
kev smoking talk about batman
and then when i came on i [ __ ] it up
because it became less specifically
about batman even though at the very
beginning it was let's watch gotham
and uh and then let's talk about what's
happening in the world let's go the
utility belt and we'll just talk about
you know rando pop culture [ __ ] for
that's right at a
certain point the utility belt became
the entire show
because gotham uh wasn't enough to
sustain
a weekly conversation believe it or not
kids there was a time
when there wasn't a lot of batman going
on there was a lot of superheroes on tv
like what's-his-name was done nolan
and you know there was no hint of bat
fleck yet
no and then that came down the road um
yeah no i i i'm sure there's some people
like
man i miss when you just interviewed
people about like batman and stuff
um which could always still be done but
i you know kind of go where
my interests and passions lie and if i
was so still interested in that
we would still be doing that i'd still
be interviewing people doing deep dives
on batman as the show evolved to what it
is that's what i became
more interested in like oh i'd like i'd
much rather talk about all of this stuff
and
batman could be a part of it and whatnot
and then
and now we're here i remember the first
time like hey all right
uh come on fat man batman you be a guest
uh just think of your 10 favorite batman
moments
and i was like all right cool and i made
that list and then you're like oh
[ __ ] it now let's uh let's do a
commentary track for dark knight returns
we'll do the batman moments later
okay we never did the batman moments do
you save them still
i think they're still on my desktop
somewhere on my computer at home but
that's that's what's beautiful about you
you're nimble you could pivot
sure all right man let's do commentary
track what you got
what's um what has it been
like for for you over the course of
since you've joined the show
what has changed like what's changed for
you um
i mean personally almost everything you
know
like before i was on the show you moved
out here
i moved out here uh and when i moved out
here was still a journalist and i was a
journalist for you know the first
couple of years of the podcast right
working for the hollywood reporter i
think i might have been at playboy for a
stretch while i was here and then the la
times
you were yeah um so and then the shift
into
writing the stuff that we usually talk
about you know like and that was a
massive
major life change yeah um and then just
the the the evolution of being
comfortable talking about [ __ ] in front
of people
like i've never been like bashful about
it or afraid of it but also never
engaged in it or had a desire to do it
right
you know i had moderated panels at comic
book conventions and then got the
the chance to stand in front of
thousands of people and talk about stuff
but it was never about me was always
about facilitating a conversation
very true i was one of those people
you've still taken a conversation with
indeed and like it's that's fun
especially because nobody's there to see
you
and your job is to be somewhat invisible
and kind of just like
you guys talk and i'm gonna ask a
question every three minutes if you're
doing your jobs well
um but to then be the reason why people
are showing up
in any slight sliver percentage that's
the real brown stone right there
that's the real you know smoke it while
you got it yeah
um and so that that feeling of being
kind of
that moment in uh was train spotting
when the girl's getting the [ __ ]
heroin she's like that's better than any
[ __ ]
[ __ ] in the world
uh yeah and it's and and that level of
comfort i think being quote unquote on
stage
that level of comfort in um
kind of flying without a map right you
know like sure i got [ __ ] written down
here but
a lot of this is whatever you would call
improv very much
we don't we don't sit here and go like
all right so you say this i'm gonna say
this like
it's as informal as it seems you know
and so being comfortable
so much so that sometimes jc don't turn
the mics on the first few minutes of the
show
we're just entertaining one another
um and i think learning that level of
comfort
in in trusting both myself
and and and you and just being able to
roll with stuff
has helped me immensely in the going
into meetings in [ __ ] hollywood and
like all right i got to talk on my feet
for a bit i can do that
i got to pitch this for you for two and
a half you know for for an hour
all right no i can walk you through it
and i i have the confidence now
that i might not have had before that i
know
kind of how it's going to go or the very
least that i'll find a place to land
you know you're also a brand now which
is super weird
yeah yeah that's something that i got
accustomed to like early on and stuff
but for you
that was something probably not in the
offing of cards most writers are
anonymous you know they're known by
their peers known by the people that
hire them but
as you were back in the day in terms of
like ah here's judd apatow kevin smith
zack snyder
frank miller you're happy to present
people when you're in the mark bernard
business
you're presenting yourself and so i over
the course of like the last few years
it's been funny to
see your name in print usually
surrounded by
or near fat man beyond mark bernardin
and stuff like that
um yeah you've become your own
known entity yeah which is profoundly
weird
you know because i had never desired for
it
wanted it chased it but there's a
there's a very small
part of my life which is now people
knowing more about me than i know about
them
weird right it's super weird and like
people having information about you
before you walk in the room and not
because
they did research you know because sure
every meeting i go into somebody has
some sense of who i am why i'm walking
in their room
but just like being in a [ __ ] airport
and somebody's like hey man how are you
it's like
right sit me down this is a little
knowing you're
you're knowing your family's names
knowing like
oh how's picard going you know what i'm
sure like that like being able to speak
to you
on a personal level where you can like
oh like
great but you don't have the ability to
be like and how is your
thing whatever it may be yeah and so
so much of that you know has been a
little weird and and be
incredibly like wonderful and gratifying
in an odd way and the only way i figure
out how to navigate it is to just do
what you do
because you do it about as well as
anybody i've seen which is very sweet
you know treat everybody with respect
and with kindness
and and everybody who was giving you any
amount of their time
is worth that same amount of your time
and i think that that's a that's a
valuable lesson
period in life so just be [ __ ] nice
to people be kind to people
if you're having the shittiest day in
the world you can break off a minute and
be nice to somebody
because that can change everything like
[ __ ] you can be in the middle of
[ __ ] the hell on earth day and then
somebody says something powerful to you
about
stuff you've made in the past you know
put you right back on the
on the good foot and what not you know
it goes a thousand what the bible say
whatever you give out
comes back to you sevenfold then you
know i don't put much stock in that book
beyond
you know the simple morality tales it's
filled with but i always liked that
idea um and i don't give out hoping for
sevenfold but you just
you know you get what you give man so
you give people your time
guess what you get their time and most
of the people that i'm interacting with
have already given me their time
i want more of their [ __ ] time so
naturally i'm like tell them everything
about yourself
that's those are it's you realize like
how important
people whose names some you'll know come
to know by name personally and whatnot
like
you know jamie obviously come to know
deacon while i've known him for years
and stuff but
nate does all our artwork on our shows
and stuff
how would we come to know him just by
sitting here familiarity and whatnot
chit chatting after shows and stuff it's
you know you're talking to people who
give you a lot of their time
every [ __ ] show we did here that
table had the same people
sitting at it so i'll have nothing but
time for those cats for the rest of my
life
you know and same with anyone that's
like oh i like your [ __ ] oh i heard this
[ __ ] or i like when you guys do that
yeah i mean i think that that i tell my
kids this all the time
that as as you get older your world will
get bigger
you know and when you're a kid your
world is insular it's just a house and
when you go to school it becomes your
classmates when you go to big school
there's more people when you get a job
it's bigger and then the older you get
you begin to focus on more of that world
and when you get to be a parent then
you're not just focused on yourself
and your friends and now your family but
the world at large
that your child will eventually walk
into and
this experience has has exploded that
world even further which now not just me
not just my family not just my friends
but now strangers on the internet are
people that i do care about
but i that i want to know that they're
okay and then when they come
you know interact with me on on their
social medias or in in person whatever
it is
like that sense that we're all okay
right that's we're good you're good
you need anything if i can help you in
any way
within reason and set some limits but
still
like i'm invested in your well-being
even if i've never met you before
because you seem to be invested in mine
for reasons that are
beyond my comprehension so at the very
least
i give a [ __ ] which is this is mark's
morning after scrooge right here
boy go buy a goose like a fine goose
here's [ __ ] it could you imagine
throwing a kid 400
expecting to get a goose back that's
that's the most
unbelievable part of the book i'll buy
the three ghosts
and jacob marley i'll buy all that [ __ ]
but some [ __ ] poor kid is handed a
bunch of gold
and he's like yeah i'm gonna come back
with a goose [ __ ] you old man
i don't even know your [ __ ] name that
boy got on a boat went to a place called
america and became
j.p morgan
and you know what he didn't do give
people money for google [ __ ] no
he's like a penny saved does it been
here i don't know if he came up with
that but whatever
um it's been a blast and hopefully it
gets to continue to be blessed
one of my favorite things about this
show and we joke about it all the time
but i
absolutely do adore it is i got into
this business because i wanted to
self-express
but the byproduct of that is relevancy
um
what you learn pretty quickly once you
become known
is oh i want that feeling to continue
forever because
if it ever dips below a certain point
again then i'm
i'm back where i was before i was quote
unquote well known or whatever like that
so um relevancy
matters now i'm not the kind of guy that
chases relevancy with
the work that he does you know like or
or earns relevancy by the work that he
does
chris nolan relevant kevin smith
still talking about clerks you know so
every once in a while he pulls a [ __ ]
curveball out but there's a
you know relevancy is like one of my
favorite things but also
like my achilles heel and whenever we do
a show
i don't know how long it's been going on
maybe somebody could go do the research
but
for years now comicbook.com comic book
resources
all of the comic book comic book twitter
likes this show and respects the show
and even if we don't have any true news
and all the news is him reading news
from somebody else
it's reassuring for whatever reason
coming from us it has some weird bizarre
validation because like well they talked
about it on the show
um and that has made the difference
because you know whenever we do the show
for the next week i see in my feed
pop-up
articles about you know uh well they
said on fat man beyond
and i'm like that's that's really nice
it's not why i did it
wasn't one of the goals where it's like
i want this [ __ ] show to be an
authority
on things or you know be quoted and
stuff but that had happened
like now i would hate to see it go away
it's one of my favorite
things about it man i mean so like
you're like nerd cronkite
like cronkite was a news man but like he
wasn't like
interviewing people he wasn't breaking
news people would bring him the news
they'd give him the copy and he just
read it and like that you would you
would trust that if cronkite said it it
was vetted because he wouldn't say [ __ ]
that he didn't think was valid
but he wasn't [ __ ] like out there
pounding pavement like breaking stories
he's just reading the copy that's in
front of him and so like yeah we didn't
right now we just lost the walter
cronkite audience like he was a lot more
than that
i saw good night and good luck you son
of a [ __ ] and i know he was a newsman
of american stature
he cried the day kennedy died you
monsters yeah
somebody told him kennedy yeah
tear here yeah it's like is this real
yeah yeah well
[ __ ] um so like and on the rare occasion
we do break news
when it's like hey there apparently is a
joel schumacher cut of batman forever
it's literally broke news yeah and then
it becomes oh oh [ __ ] this is
well damn okay cool it's been nice
having that
yeah nice little piece of credibility
one more [ __ ]
you know arrow in the quiver just in
case be able to pull out defend yourself
against
uh uh what's the thing i'm worried about
all the time
irrelevancy thank you oh there's that
word he who shall not be named
shopping for a prefix um thank you
though to everybody the audience that
tunes in
people are here watching on youtube
watch on on
uh on facebook who listen to the actual
podcast and stuff like that
thanks for making us a [ __ ] thing
because some cool shits come from
we've gotten to go to things we were
never going to go to
and see things we weren't ever going to
see early because of this dippy show
yeah
we got to [ __ ] hit the road for a
little bit when there was a road you
could hit we could go out on stages and
stuff yeah
i'm in cleveland now that's cool i
remember remember we went to detroit for
the freak at film fest and
and like did fat man be on at the that
giant
at the fillmore yeah that was nuts we
went to tiny towns in
in canada st john remember that little
fishing village yes
yes newfoundland yes that was great
we've been around man we've been here
and we're ain't going nowhere
no when the world orients itself again
yeah back on the road when kovitz dead
we'll be [ __ ] right in your faces
again
with branded masks fat man
do you guys think the show helped you
get like the masters of the universe on
netflix
even if not directly because you guys
work together so closely
here that they're like oh mark's doing
stuff oh and kevin oh and they're
friends let's
bring the team i'll tell you what it i
didn't help
i honestly think it did help him as much
as
like this helped cement oh
he's like in that space and he talks
about that [ __ ] and he
like you know it just solidified a
reputation but
what helped masters of the universe was
sitting next to mark all this time and
going like goddammit you're a good
storyteller so when it came time to be
in charge of the story
and remind you we would sit here and be
like why don't anyone give off the next
show
dear netflix where's our show so once
somebody was like here's a netflix show
i was smart enough to be like well he
knows how to tell [ __ ] stories
and you know i just uh did a
watch with tim one of our writers so it
was me
and mark and eric and tim
and dia so tim came over to watch
all of the animatics so far there are
nine
um because he's going to be working on
uh
the comic book so tim came in to like
see everything from
top to bottom and he was just like oh my
god three is so [ __ ] good i was like
right
that was mark um so it's standing next
to him
for years and going like that's [ __ ]
good like oh my god i want to watch your
movie
like made it easy as [ __ ] when i had
somebody to pull i was like i know a
[ __ ] writer and stuff um and i do
feel like
this is one more platform to be out
there like you know on hollywood babylon
we
would do geek news but nobody thinks of
hollywood babylon
as like a geek show
it's like comedy like you know a
nightclub show this actually oddly
became
a backdoor news show and then it became
a full-on news show which
because like we're in it every week
going
here's what's coming out here's what we
like uh what about this what if they did
this
you just start becoming a like oh
they're
they're they're well [ __ ] red in this
world
um it was one more you know [ __ ]
again arrow in the quiver for me so that
i think
it it had to help because when they
reached out to me when mattel did and
even like when they brought me into
netflix
it was like oh [ __ ] kevin smith of
course
and i don't have anything in my work
that
says masters you don't watch clerks or
mall rats and go oh that guy could do
[ __ ] motu
it's all of this that you know [ __ ]
makes him go like oh well he's
definitely
well versed in this stuff and i'll tell
you man like that motu
miniseries is like one of the things i'm
most proud of
anything i've been involved with in my
career because
it it's its own unique thing it don't
look like anything i've ever done
it looks like the thing that we know
from childhood but then grown up and
stuff like that
and i i do believe that it had something
to do with getting this job
or getting that job i mean i've i've
absolutely had you know interactions
with people
that i had never met before who only
knew me from the podcast
who were like hey so uh i i'm making a
movie
and it's being produced by columbia and
i really like
this [ __ ] you say on the podcast you
want to sit down and talk about it
you know whether that becomes like i'd
like you to write my movie
or can can i like throw you some
consultancy work just to read some stuff
and see if it makes sense i've had
video game companies reach out and say
hey man like i just i really like your
story sense do you have
two years you can devote to this video
game and i'll say no but thank you
that's really sweet um
and i think that it also there are
executives in hollywood who are just
kind of
looking for reasons to meet with people
because that's part of their job like if
you're a creative executive in hollywood
the work is how many new people did you
meet with right um you know what's your
appointment book look like and
in casting about for people to sit down
and talk to some of them listen to the
podcast i'm like hey [ __ ] let's sit
down and talk to that dude
um some people listen to it after the
meeting i'm like oh
[ __ ] i didn't know you were that guy
it's it either it's function as both
like helping to get work
and also reinforcing the interactions
with people in the world as long as it
doesn't keep us from getting work
you know which was always the fear too
at one point it's like well i mean how
much can we say
that we like and don't like without
[ __ ] ourselves
but but i will say that i've i've had
meetings at companies
that have made movies or tv shows that i
haven't liked
and it hasn't bit me in the ass knock on
wood so far
right um we'll let him get into here too
yeah and then we'll spring it on him
um you know or it's it's a thing where
if it it has bit me in the ass i don't
know it
like maybe the meetings i could have had
that they decided let's not call that
dude
he really [ __ ] all over that thing that
we made you know like i don't think i'm
going into vin diesel's production
company anytime soon
that was your pick your go-to pick oh
you know the one thing that i know is
never going to happen
um although just watch like hey you want
to write fast and furious 10
don't show vin diesel any of this it's
true once but once i start watching fast
and furious and we start discussing it
they're going to hear your open mind on
the subject of the bill like he's
brilliant he's great oh but bring the
gun
how can you do his voice i know i don't
watch those movies so i only know him as
i am groot so i got to do that
but they put him through a filter yeah
iron giant it's very
he's like you gotta
do that yeah very it's very gravelly
but also like with this weird family
hashtag
franken diesel
all right ladies and gentlemen uh enough
of us sucking our own
bat dicks or fed dicks on brand for the
show which sounds hotter
i know and dirtier i can't wait for the
fast and by curious podcast
that's a great title and it will be
coming a podcast within a podcast yeah
um inception that's right we're
incepting our own [ __ ] podcast
we're taking it beyond fat man beyond
into the bi-curious
fast and vicarious um sooner or later
that's to happen but right now
god damn it we're going to celebrate 300
episodes of fat man beyond by doing what
we always do
turning to mark and being like what's
going on in the news mark hey
i opened my second liquored up
this is mango mango gotta be good right
let's watch my face and see got to be
good
does it have to be i'll play with that
there's no more black cherry got no
choice
i'm sorry um regardless i'm bitching man
just get me there
make me drunk
[Music]
hey baby how you doing just take me to
that place
just do your magic uh so
jc went off to get the door dash which i
think is probably more black cherry but
like
yes uh that's a boost run
um hey i watched i watched a movie
oh listen to you bragger i watched a
movie you know that thing that's so rare
these days
yeah what in a theater no oh let's not
be crazy although i did have a friend
who went down to uh to huntington beach
she and her boyfriend
and they had a cinemark down there you
could rent out a whole house
for like you know one of the screens
yeah 150 bucks
they gave her the whole thing yeah koi
from uh the
andrew yeah question andrew from the uh
schmodown amongst other things he did
that for his birthday he was like it's
only like 150 bucks to ran a theater
yeah
we should do that i mean it's a little
far yeah where'd they go
they're hunting it beach so that's the
oc because there's no place in it f
in the a that seems rather far but what
can we do that here this is only 150
bucks to
i mean there's no theaters in l.a that
are open that are open but when they
open
is it only generally 150 bucks i think
it's usually more expensive than that
but everything else
[ __ ] whatever we can get to come in if
we if they do that deal here when they
open theaters and [ __ ] that's the only
way i'm going to go see movies
um that's worth it i mean i mean think
about what you pay
to go on two-person like you take your
wife out to a movie back before the
the coven mm-hmm like 40 to 50 bucks
easy for another hundred dollars you
have the room yourself you could [ __ ]
in the movie and i'm sure they probably
write on the thing like
please don't [ __ ] [ __ ] in the movie
theater because i [ __ ] sure would
uh man that does sound like a sweet deal
anyway what'd you see uh
i watched on the netflix i watched enola
homes
oh that's the series with the little
girl that everybody loves so much
what's her name very specific yes millie
bobby brown that's it she's got many
names
yes jackie earl haley or lee harvey
oswald she's either going to be a kid
actress or an
assassin right i was going to go jackie
join a cursey olympian
but but i guess i look i guess people
with three names do
all sorts of things there's like four
careers open but in my mind
kid actors killers
yeah and popes as in pope john paul
there you go
pope john paul ringo
um so yeah so she plays uh sherlock
holmes's
younger sister is based on a series of
books that i never read indeed
neither did i but it it popped up on my
netflix which i already paid for i was
like [ __ ] it in all homes
um it is enchanting it is also wildly
uneven
um and like the longest two-hour movie
you'll ever watch because
the second act is like what's happening
i don't understand but she's great
is it a movie or a show it's a movie so
it's only like two hours it's a two-hour
movie
um henry cavill i'm in you might
actually push me into watching because i
thought it was a series i'm like
i got time for that that's too busy
watching the boys i don't want to see
but a two-hour movie i'll dive in for
yeah
and um it is it is a charming
misfire you know like it's compare it to
young sherlock holmes the movie of our
childhood
um less actiony i think than young
sherlock holmes yeah
yorkshire homes there's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's got some sword fighters [ __ ]
remember the
romite the cult scene and [ __ ] where
they sacrifice people
i'll never forget being in that theater
be like this [ __ ] just took a metal
jump holy [ __ ] why didn't they put this
in the trailer man like i was here for
the sword fighting the cg [ __ ]
skeleton from the
glass thing but i will stay for the
[ __ ] egyptian
death cult oh that was so bad lead with
the egyptian death deal next and then he
turned out spoilers if you watch the
credits
they had a post-marvel a post-credits
scene before marvel ooh what was that
was i don't remember they
uh show at the end of it you know
[ __ ] remember the egyptian dude
[ __ ]
perished or whatever the [ __ ] and then
the girl that he was in love with she
passed and then he left and
watson was like i'd catch up to him
years later then they show like a
carriage driving through the countryside
through most of the credits and [ __ ]
then after the credits were done
that the guy they got out of carriage
went into the
into the like a hotel or motel or
whatever the version of it back in the
day was holiday inn
on an inn or something like that and
they asked him to sign the book
and he signed it moriarty and then they
panned up to him and it was the [ __ ]
dude
who was his teacher who became the
egyptian death cult god
and [ __ ] like that so the implication
was
that we saw the secret origin of
moriarty
i'm telling you that movie was so
[ __ ] good young sherlock holmes
i think it's on the disney plus is it i
think it's [ __ ] great it's a
wonderful flick i remember being
completely blown away by the movie it
still holds up
i haven't seen it into this but the
trailer was like all like tea and
crumpets
it's a young sherlock and instead you
get there and they're like we're gonna
[ __ ] sacrifice a little girl i was
like
holy [ __ ] i'm down for this what a great
movie it's like i'm sure walt was like
we can't we can't sell that put that on
the back shelf please that was what was
it barry
levinson or the or who
who directed young sherlock holmes i
feel like that's super early for barry
levinson because that's that's pretty
diner and diner was his first jam
you're right good point so maybe it's
bob zemeckis
i wonder if it's nicholas meyer no he
did time after time that was which is uh
barry levinson all right
what up relevant showdown champion
relevant i can answer questions about
[ __ ] happened back in the 80s
it was barry levinson right because i
remember it was like this is a
completely uncharacteristic movie from
the guy who made diner
wow well good nice so yes enola homes
totally enjoyable kind of doesn't make a
ton of sense henry cavill
is the most jacked sherlock holmes will
ever see like he's literally
he loads his guns but he's painted into
these like [ __ ] victorian frocks with
the height and like come on he's like a
he's like the the luther in umbrella
academy
if you haven't seen umbrella academy
anyway he's a dude it's kind of mixed
with like simian dna
right and so he's always wearing these
like track suits and [ __ ] with these
giant
arms that's what henry cavill looks like
just
like he can't when he puts his arms by
his side his hands don't touch his body
because the muscles are because there's
so much up yeah
you're making me jealous stop i know
it's weird um and he's he's playing
an incredibly emotional sherlock holmes
is he really he is
i love you i mean sherlock holmes is
my favorite description was by benedict
cumberbatch he's a high functioning
sociopath
here he's like a concerned older brother
right and it's like but that's not
exactly who sherlock holmes is
for the most part he's a dick like a
whose fault is a script or actor
i think it's it's script because the
script is giving him a lot of like i
care for you and ola i want the best for
you and all even though my brother
mycroft seems to be the dick than i'm
supposed to be
but like there was a chance for some
really interesting tension having henry
cavill who you want to look at
and just think is a nice person because
he's superman
playing an asocial kind of sociopath
and that tension would have been
interesting but they didn't go that way
to the point where now there's a lawsuit
from the home's estate from the arthur
conan doyle estate oh sam this ain't
[ __ ] homes
well like most of them no homes no
uh our homes homezy don't play that
um most of the sherlock holmes other
conan doyle estate is in the public
domain
which is why everybody gets to make a
sherlock movie but the latter
the tail end of those books are still
part of the copyright and in those books
he becomes a warmer softer person
because the audience at some point the
reading audience was like
why should we'll be such a dick all the
time so they said like in the end
and arthur conan doyle started writing
them softer yeah and so they're saying
hey that's
not that stuff is still now it's a
copyright case because you're stealing
from the stuff that you can't steal from
very tricky tricky tricky like homes or
elementary we should say the game
is a foot yes which they say a dozen
times because of course you do
you gotta um so i guess that sort of
dovetails into the news a bit the
copyright case but
i was like oh [ __ ] i'll watch 11 and
superman
do some cool [ __ ] and i was entertained
i watched uh a netflix thing
what murder next door american story
about the guy who like
true crime yeah it was nuts i didn't
know this story man it's crazy this dude
who's like
my wife just came back from a thing and
she disappeared my kids are gone and
you know everyone went looking for them
and finally you know they were like
police were working on them and they're
like well
we don't really believe your story and
you know they got the footage of him
going well
i mean i told the truth and then they
just like
dude starts cracking killed his wife
just because he didn't want to be
married no more but problem is he had
two kids
so he took his wife's dead body put it
in the car
with the two kids who were like three
and fours daughters
who they've got this mom was like a big
facebook person
so the whole documentary is [ __ ]
haunting it's made up of
all this footage that she shot herself
of her family of her two daughters and
her and her husband
on [ __ ] facebook and then it's made
up of the police
camera footage and of the interview room
footage and [ __ ] like that
so it's no real interviews of people
like talking head stuff it's all
all footage leading up to [ __ ]
haunting so
he he strangles his wife
he puts her in the [ __ ] truck with
the two kids and the kid and he carries
her and she's like in a sheet
and the kid's like what's wrong with
mommy he's like nothing and he goes to a
[ __ ]
oil site that he was working at and
strangles the two kids and throws them
in a [ __ ] oil well bro oh
[ __ ] i'm telling you i was like this
left me so broken after i watched this
and you know anything that's murder in
the title i should not expect good
things from
but i didn't think this was the story
man but it was very well made and [ __ ]
and apparently like jennifer's like
everybody knows the story i was like i
then i'm happy to be a nobody because
up until this moment i didn't know this
and [ __ ] yeah i don't need this [ __ ]
in my head
yeah oh yeah that's the thing that's
what i felt like afterwards but it was
incredibly well made
have you been watching the vow yes you
two
yeah that of course it's on like [ __ ]
what goes up with lovecraft
so i watch one and the other that's
another thing i mean but still
i get it because they've now done a
great series and showing how smart
people can be duped by
you know the [ __ ] nimrod like this
guy and to be
joining a sex cult getting branded and
stuff
they've done a fine job presenting the
case i still have a disconnect where i'm
like you couldn't [ __ ]
the moment they talk about branding you
that's when you get the [ __ ] up and
run the first time i'm like we need to
take naked pictures of you for
collateral
too it's just like anybody that's like
well we need something on you in case
you go wrong it's like that ain't
good that's not like healthy for the
mind body that's
not progressive that just although then
again and the guy that's such a zero man
he's super zero like when you see him
you're like this this
is all it took like pseudo-intellectual
[ __ ] but is there
a version i mean there is a version and
it's probably wrong although it might
not be
where that's his name
yeah keith ranieri where the the worst
iterations
of the catholic church could employ
confessional
as getting collateral yeah but they
don't know who you are
they would have to put a camera on you
like when you walk into a confessional
right there's no
screen right theoretically i mean as far
as you know they don't know who you are
good point you mean i'm [ __ ] father
dave in the 70s
he's got footage of me going i touch
myself god please don't tell anybody
and he's like i've got compramot
but it's true like if you had a camera
in the church like and i'm sure their
churches put cameras in them now you
know for that [ __ ] purpose so
not for that purpose so that you know
vandalism and [ __ ] like that
but if you've got a camera in the church
and you got a
[ __ ] even if you don't have a camera
in the conventional booth but you got a
like audio recorder
you got a picture and you got a [ __ ]
sound you could totally [ __ ]
have information on you could literally
just have a lot on catholics you could
have like a
a like of an organist just paying
attention to who's walking into this
and all the priest has to do is remember
which write that [ __ ] down
here's what i heard in this hour that i
was in confessional who walked into that
thing oh that was kevin smith
kevin smith that guy write that [ __ ]
down
and yet and you know i was involved in
the catholic church for quite some time
as a kid
and into adulthood um never heard of a
single [ __ ] case
of someone's [ __ ] being used against
them in
confession you know what i'm saying you
never heard like on the that would be a
big news story because that would be a
huge scandal it's like you could get
your [ __ ]
rocked by going to one of the sacraments
that you're supposed to go to as a
catholic
that's a good shut the [ __ ] up that's a
good story thing man
shut up never mind he didn't say that
darn kardash [ __ ] that's a good story
right there dude
uh catholic church is in trouble right
like [ __ ] membership falling
parishes closing everywhere and [ __ ] how
do you keep how do you keep the powerful
people there the influential people how
do you keep the
influencers you know you [ __ ]
threaten a
black man
that sounds like an ira 11 book from the
70s
sacrament yes yes
the eighth sacrament because there's
only seven
um i i'm digging the vowel but i feel as
if
it's it's a third too long i agree
they're really stretching it
yeah especially because we know what
happened like by episode two
it's like uh but sex cult episode three
branding vaginas episode four
he meets the dalai lama but also it's
like we
like this happened yes and so we all
know that everyone went down and [ __ ]
like so we know what the
third act is right like even if you
didn't it just doesn't have a lot of
shoes to drop
um because once you drop branded vaginas
you're like oh [ __ ] what's next and to
be fair it's above but it's close
enough close enough if it's like if
if somebody's like we want to put a
tattoo in your pubic
area above your dick it's not going to
be anywhere on your dick or your balls
i'd be like
they wouldn't finish the sentence i'd be
like i'm sorry did you say
branding why pardon me yes
branding pudenda if they're like we want
to put a guy named brandon on your dick
i'm like all right well let me ask my
wife
but if they're talking about permanently
branding like a [ __ ] cow
any like the one girl don't ask her
husband or not ask her husband but like
you think this is a good idea for me to
be in a secret society that i'm not
supposed to tell you about
babe uh i know thursday whatever pizza
night here's the thing
um was it cool if they like brand me
right above
my vagina how crimson was it well
she figured out it was that dude's
initials yes that was [ __ ] up because
it wasn't just like this women's group
symbol it was like literally it's the
mountains
in the horizon yeah and the sun's like
shifted sideways
and it's [ __ ] key oh yeah and you
have to watch this [ __ ] zero
talk like it's you know i
i don't know i'm not gonna say like i
wouldn't have fallen for it but i don't
think i would have fallen for that
no no but it was interesting [ __ ] that
they talk about how like he would have
him play
volleyball at one two in the morning and
they all jockeyed to do it so they could
be around him but that's also a mind
control
technique it's about like exhausting
people
and [ __ ] like that and then having them
work on your schedule it's crazy man
it's worth a watch and [ __ ] but he's
right it's a little bit
it feels like they were seduced by
footage because like yeah
obscene amount of footage while all this
[ __ ] was going on
that was the crazy thing to me is that
one guy
mark who was like one of the heads he
recorded like
personal conversations with his wife
like
if jen and i were getting in a fight and
i was like hold on honey i'm going to
tape this just in case
she'd be like put your phone down like
the dude recorded
every conversation he had for like 10
years yeah
that's creepy weird he's a filmmaker if
you're not watching it he's a filmmaker
who made a movie years ago called what
the bleep do we know
so at a certain point like he was their
media guy where he was shooting
you know following keith ranieri who
he's the guy that breaks my heart the
most because he seemed to really [ __ ]
believe in this
he was in it like in and for 12 [ __ ]
years and then one day was like oh my
god this is a sham
but they've got footage going back they
got footage of allison mack from
smallville
meeting him for the first time and
apparently that's the episode i keep
waiting for
like where i'm like give me the all mac
episode
you're the magician she's the one that
like facilitated
like she it was him then her then all
these other
slaves and masters which anybody like
hey you're going to be in a secret
society and we're just using these words
they don't mean anything but you have to
use them
doesn't that make you go like i don't
know if i want to be involved in
something like this
well i think it you know to that point
noteworthy and i've been paying
attention
not a ton of black people in there yeah
you know why because the minute you
start calling people thrown out words
like that
[ __ ] this time to go fell for that once
didn't like it moving on very true it's
so weird that's true i didn't notice
that
yeah i'm like oh this there's but and
i'm also like watching for the battle
star people
because i know that's true yeah though
nikki klein who played cali
and then there's another one too yeah
like nikki klein is deep into it i think
she's now married to allison mack
what yeah that girl from battlestar
galactica and allison mack are married
yeah
isn't allison mack in jail you can be
married to somebody who's in jail
oh good point alton mack is on
house arrest she's not in jail so she's
not in jail but she's like
serving time for a crime she got
convicted
she got convicted of a crime but like
you know she married the girl
from battlestar galactica mm-hmm what
and this is the first time hearing of it
see there's more in this documentary you
know
like they better get to that episode but
like every now and again it's like oh
there's grace park and
yeah but she was in an episode too yeah
it seemed like because there was a
vancouver office everyone that shot up
there they got a few
a few battle star people a few uh
small people because who's the other
kristen crook yeah
she played a lot of wang right so yeah
so yeah there's there's and i keep
hoping to please don't see anybody else
please no more battlestar people come on
guys
you all seem smart come on not uh
not uh what's number six trisha yeah
i've been like fear of like please don't
see trisha please don't see trisha
and then like i texted her i was like
i'm watching the vows she's like it's
crazy right
i'm like i'm not gonna see you like now
when you say it's crazy
do we mean we both think it's crazy yeah
it's definitely worth the watch it's
called the val it is about
axiom it's coming to its end like
episode seven was last week i think
episode eight might be this week
yeah um so but it's it's it's absolutely
worth
just watching the dumb [ __ ] people will
do to find a way to make themselves feel
better
katherine and oxenberg really stepping
up yeah i know because somebody was like
you know born royal and [ __ ] like that
she's literally in it to save her kid
like any
any mom like i was very impressed by her
uh and as much as
she's you know she seems dialed in it's
not like
somebody's downloading a report for her
she's
she's trying to save her did she do it
does anybody know
of a kid india did she pull her out of
that i don't know i'm assuming that's
the only part of the story that i'm
unfamiliar with whatever happened that's
why i keep like i wonder what happens
with
her and her daughter yeah i know the
other guy goes to jail doesn't he
rainier yeah i think he does yeah
but yeah and i had just watched like for
sex trafficking
amongst other things there were weird
charges but very much so but i just
watched like sharktopus versus
barracantala or something right
um but and you're like now i need
something just as real
indeed but like casper van deen is the
star of all those things
and he was he was mr catherine oxford he
was mr kevin and she's
in one of those things i'm like i we
just saw her in that shitty shark
barracuda movie
she was in uh him and her with those
left behind movies
that's right um yeah it's worth watching
it's definitely worth a watch man as is
of course [ __ ] um
lovecraft country which that must be
wrapping up soon right yeah
i mean tonight did you watch last week's
episode i did watch last night
like all i could think about last week's
episode was
you're the actress who they hired to
play
that part who was uh courtney b vance's
wife in the show anjanue ellis
who has like you know a
bit parts up until that episode
and they don't tell you like when you're
doing a show here's ten
here's the 10 scripts they give them to
you one a week generally speaking
so you're that actress you took the job
you're like right on there's great
people on this i got a cool part like
i'm here great then one day they're like
the whole episode is about you and like
you
get to play yeah ten different versions
of a possible version yourself all i
could think watching this episode is how
happy that actress must have been to be
like
oh my god i'm gonna get to show off
every [ __ ] range that i can like what
a gift and stuff and did they tell her
when they hired her you're gonna have an
episode all to yourself and when they
told her that
did she even conceive of what that meant
right yeah that's fascinating because i
mean i i have to think that
misha green at some point like by the
time you're casting
you're like we kind of know what the
season is like everything's not written
yet but here's
kind of what episodes one through eight
or one through ten are going to be
by the way you're gonna really like
seven
oh my god it was it was a wonderful
episode but like as
as great as the content was and it went
everywhere and it was like
just just a real thing just a trip man
like
total sci-fi trip and really detours
from the main story leaves out all the
main characters
except her makes it all about her which
even in the grand scheme of the
the entire series like you don't feel
good just her as an actress you feel
good for a character who has always been
a support system in not just the lives
of these characters but the story that
we're watching
suddenly she gets to take center stage
and like
crushed it it was such a great episode
yeah it's this you know
lovecraft country has been a really
interesting watch because it
i i'm a person who loves narrative and
who loves plot and who
and character as well clearly you can't
have one without the other but i always
look for things to kind of
swiss watch like make sense and
lovecraft
seems fundamentally not interested in
that right it is living on this like
magical realism
tone poem level where it's just we're
telling this story
and it almost doesn't matter if this
part of the story keys in at all to any
main narrative it's going to answer any
questions you might have about the show
we're just going to do this [ __ ] now
where she just trips through some
magical
reality machine and sees the versions of
herself
that could have been if they lived or
were that's when i got out of the story
she lived every one of those
lives yeah like and it's it's a
dimension
time machine more than it's just a time
machine and like does it make sense
no does it have to make sense turns out
no and and just like swimming in those
emotional realities
is has been really refreshing both as a
viewer and as a storyteller just like oh
you know if you can just find the
emotional truth of your characters
you can do almost anything and if your
audience is on board
they will 100 roll with you and i'm on
board i love what they're [ __ ] doing
over there
telling great stories did you see misha
put up somebody
tweeted a question going like how do you
pitch a show like this
and she was like i'll show you and she
put up there was a set of like 12 or 15
or 20 note cards
but the top note card was visible and
readable
and it was you know um
uh hp lovecraft is a celebrate you know
all the usual wikipedia [ __ ] for the
first three sentences about who
lovecraft was and he has his own genre
uh love crafty and blah blah and then
she wrote he
also wrote and then put up some of his
really hardcore racist [ __ ]
and then talked about like you know so
through this lens we're going to examine
his work like
in the first note card she you know
she said the revolution is going to be
televised this is what it's going
this is what it is and this is what it's
going to be so if you're in the room
listening to that pitch by the time she
gets the middle of the card
you you know the top of it talking about
lovecraft you're like oh i've heard of
him yeah but then when she hits the
racist stuff you're like oh oh
i'm paying attention hold on yeah you
mean it's not just weird sci-fi [ __ ]
yeah no yeah so you know i'm sure some
people like well it doesn't help to
hurt to walk in with jj and [ __ ]
jordan
peel as well but even without those cats
the card that i read
would have been very hard to like walk
out of that pitch and not be like
we should look into this right it was it
was you should have more meetings
yeah we should also maybe say yes i
watched the thing on hulu called monster
land
oh i saw the trailers it's an anthology
series and there's an episode
uh i don't know quite how to describe it
it's like very twilight zonian very
black mirror
um and monsters are a theme kind of but
like it's really but we
are the monsters but there's one that's
like incredibly moving and heartbreaking
um if you've ever dealt with somebody
with not
just an addiction problem with somebody
with a like bipolar or something like
that
it's a love story about these two women
and it's like
it's the girl from um i never watched
the show but uh
orange is the new black she was on
twitter was the tv show taylor schilling
she played cher when it was a tv show
but then she's had a career of course
since then
she was [ __ ] fantastic in this and
then the other actors who had never seen
before was amazing
but they tell a story about um
loving somebody who is
you know challenged
um and it's a heartbreaking [ __ ]
story yeah freight told through the
prism
like since it's called monsterland every
episode there's a monster the
this is uh told through the prism of the
undead
so it's kind of like a zombie story to
some degree but it was
there's each one a standalone mike
coulter was in one that was set in
newark new jersey and they even
referenced harrison i was like what the
[ __ ]
and that's about him and his wife like
losing a
child and then finding this
angel this monster looks like a vampire
and [ __ ]
um really well done but i still it would
take a smart person
to watch it and go oh the theme is this
i can't quite put my
finger on it but really well-made
anthology stuff
and then there's a netflix show which
somebody has been trying to get me to
watch
and they've hit up you i think as well
on twitter
um it's from maybe chile or something
like that
it's a [ __ ]
not secret identity or something like
that but it's
it looks like a hero superhero thing but
the director was like
please watch it and he had a bunch of
fans hitting us
up going like you guys have to watch
this which i've yet to watch so i'll be
watching that
this week yeah like once i once i back
off of shit's creek
you're on a marathon i'm on a marathon
because they hey they go down so [ __ ]
easy
22 minutes each like for real sitcoms
they said about my wife
goes down thank you very much 22 minutes
long that's what they said about my
um and i dig it like it's just it's
super easy
and like feel good is the wrong word
because they're all awful people
um but it just it's it's
it's it's like warm milk in a way like
oh
you know all right cool that was
pleasant
and occasionally like out loud funny but
mostly just pleasant and i could use a
little
just pleasant right about now
i'm in a just pleasant place after
finishing yeah baby second one
all right should we do some real news we
haven't started no i'm probably not
gonna make it to questions if i crack
open this third
oh we got bloodline seltzer ladies and
gentlemen if you want to get
drunk and not notice gently rocked
yes and then suddenly you're like whoa
oh
look who's in me liquor
bud light seltzer that's for you
mark tell them what news we got look
who's in me
kevin smith
um this better be about jamie foxx the
man
has seen the headlines i did jamie foxx
is back as electro for spider-man 3
homeward bound
that's not what they're called whatever
they're calling i um
at first was like why but now i'm like
i'll take it
um i was not a wild fan of uh
this flick no particularly this
take incarnation of electro either uh
so oddly enough um
when they when i first read this story i
was like are you sure
then i read it deeper and i was like you
know what that would be actually cool
here's a chance to put them in the
costume here's a chance to
here's a chance to do the sinister six
which is what i think they're building
i think they're building toward and and
it's all he's an amazing actor i don't
blame that [ __ ]
movie on him but i didn't care for that
his take on electric
no but i also think that this this and
the jk simmons
tail end of of the willingness to create
a spider-verse
like we're getting it now like and
they're leaning into it for real like
the the
oh whatever i don't know maybe at some
point miles morales
and peter parker in live action will be
hanging they're gonna meet
they're gonna meet like they're gonna
look they're gonna give us that shot
that keeps showing on the internet
of three different spidermans toby
andrew
and uh and the current kid tom right
they're gonna give us that shot
and they're gonna give us miles they're
gonna give you what you want because
look just start telling them what you
want because that's the only way they're
going to get you to go back to the
theaters
so look at what the flash movies
becoming
like [ __ ] they're like what do you
want us to put in it super friends gleek
the monkey
he's in we'll do anything we'll suck
your dick come back
yes do you want one or twins we'll get
you both winter twins and twins
now i'm being honest because i'm having
the third one of these
oh [ __ ] now you're gonna know how i feel
about all this [ __ ] in celse veritas
here we go
i went hard for episode 300
mostly seltzer um this is a great idea
yeah i kind of dig it and anything that
gets us to the sinister six quick
is a-okay in my book i like that they're
giving nods to the other universes
i like kevin foggy's good dude yeah i
mean and i think the
the again the the drilling down on what
i think the universe absolutely wants
which is
miles morales live action in the mcu
we're getting there
and every baby step that we get to that
path is a baby step i'm willing to take
love it can't wait i'm all for it he's a
wonderful actor so
hopefully they get look all i'm asking
put them in in the [ __ ] comic suit
for the classic comic suit yeah
close enough doesn't have to be exactly
yeah or
not at all what it was and amazing yeah
just don't do that
big blue marble head that he had like
give me something a little more electro
right like if if their idea of it is is
that in each one of these universes
a jamie foxx like person eventually
becomes electro great
just let it be cooler way cooler yeah
that'd be that'd be awesome um here's
the thing that made me very happy
netflix uh has decided to put into
development
a conan the barbarian television program
that makes sense who's doing it uh
unclear that according to the to the
laridah
it makes sense man why not this is good
the the the agreement between pathfinder
media which is controlled by
guys named frederick mullenberg and mark
wheeler um
is the first deal between netflix and
conan properties international
um to give netflix the exclusive option
to acquire rights to the conan literary
library and develop works across tv and
film
both live action and animate it's
[ __ ] dope i would watch a conan
series oh on netflix spending all the
money and [ __ ] like that and it can be
as violent and bloody as you want it to
be
and lots of head cutting off lots of
stew with human heads in it and [ __ ]
it can be the thing that i loved when i
was a kid reading savage sort of conan
way too early to be reading a book
called cyrus soda conan which was
nothing but like
boobs and beheadings i believe that was
a subtitle
robert howards boobs and beats um but
yeah no i'm super excited
at the even the prospect of it um it is
still a long way away from being real
but
we know that netflix wants to buy all
the ip that it can't get its hands on
for example warner's and
and hbo max has all the dc lock the
[ __ ] locked up sorry i'm drunk d [ __ ]
there's dc [ __ ] locked up
stop it disney has all the marvel [ __ ]
live
and the star wars show and the star wars
[ __ ] so netflix
always everybody else looking for what
ip is out there to be had
conan's huge known worldwide and stuff
and imagine if you did
gave them a game of thrones type budget
you know every episode would look like
[ __ ] arnold schwarzenegger's movie
yeah you know like and given what
they're spending and how
something like the witcher looks it's
like i don't watch that how is it
um it's it's it's really interesting i
didn't love the first couple of episodes
by the time you get like deep into it
like oh
okay this is kind of cool and hey henry
cavill's having a good time
and there's a bard who's a lot of fun
and yeah like it's it's worth a watch
i feel i feel like you dig it but but
yeah i mean
doing for real sword and sorcery like in
that level
of care that would be great and if
you're going to do like animated [ __ ]
also
you could get arnold back did they do
yes like if you're going to do like a
king conan show
animated and have arnold voice old conan
the barbarian i mean you could have
arnold
as your live in your live action movie
too
as remember in the movies they would
always show them at the end on the
throne and [ __ ] and
but that is a story for another time
so he could literally be the guy looking
back you know what i'm saying so every
episode could have a little bit of
arnold in it i remember when
um you know what used to be important to
me to hear the lamentation
to drive to curse crush my enemies see
the german before me
and hear the lamentation of women now a
good bowel movement that's all i care
about love king conan meditation of my
bowels
yes um i'm all up for watching this man
give it to them give them
give it to netflix yes please more also
please give them
masters universe let him make a
live-action series of that oh
oh there you go could you imagine we'd
be so close to the throne for that [ __ ]
we would definitely get to write some if
not make something
it's all upset and i'm talking about
like could you imagine if they did that
like a series
like game of thrones but it was masters
universe but they spent that much money
that's insane
i want it that's insane dare dream i say
because at some point you're gonna have
like a for real photo real battle cat
yes who's giant and green that a live
action actor will be writing in some
fashion you're going to have a land
shark you're going to have to build
castle grayskull the
jaw bridge will be a real thing you you
watch within the next [ __ ] 10 to 20
years somebody's going to do that i look
forward to the picture of kevin smith
standing on the jaw bridge
i'll visit that set because you know
they're gonna let me direct but i'll
visit that set oh i mean i have a
feeling you're never leaving that city
you ain't kidding like is he still here
yeah look at him
there he is look at him he's bugging
beast man again
man's just a guy in a green screen stop
talking to the sorceress so much
she's got work to do leave lena heady
alone
lena headey is our sorceress is [ __ ]
phenomenal
oh anyway enough about that can't wait
to show you all right what else we got
uh jj abrams is ripping us off i know
that guy what
yeah again what do you do uh jj abrams
is going all the places you'll go
to make a dr seuss animated flick for
warner bros
oh and why is that our idea um because
oh we wanted to do world war zeus we
wanted to do world war ii and this is
like the beginning of a
like warner brothers seuss kind of
connection
a suser verse uh and and yeah i wanted
we wanted to do that first
we did we had an idea on the show years
ago yes to do world war
zeus and once again somebody was
listening writing [ __ ] down
and now our idea a good idea belongs to
somebody else i wouldn't be surprised if
jj
next announces a cinderella [ __ ]
project
son of a [ __ ] uh good for him i want
more seuss but two hours
two hours i don't do you ever read a dr
seuss book
i know you did lots of times how long
does it take you mark
eight nine minutes you know what i'm
saying like even when they did the
grinch
stole christmas they stretched it at a
half an hour
these two hour movies and i say that
with nothing but affection my boy scott
mosher
co-directed the grinch movie but like
can a thing be a thing that's a small
thing
why does it have to be a feature-length
thing oh the places you'll go you can
read in 10 minutes
yeah they're all kind of peppy and quick
but you know what that's why i'm not a
[ __ ] multi-millionaire
that's why i'm not jay james because i'm
like go read a book
jj's like no i'll show it to you never
read a book again here come here
um but yeah it's gonna be feature length
animated
coming out 2027 is the is the current
objective [ __ ] what yeah
well we're getting how dare you tell us
about something that's not happening
until 2027
we're trying to get through 2020.
we got like 40 days left you might as
well be like you know what else is
coming the apocalypse eventually like
all things end
yeah no pretty much that's 2029
2027 all right well there's no point in
talking about that for another five
[ __ ] years
yeah so we'll not even not another five
[ __ ] minutes
that's it now i'm getting honest
there it is [ __ ] you seuss yeah i'm
tired of being made promises
[ __ ] you and your sousaphone promises
shmramises as dr seuss might have rhymed
himself
as long as i'm rich what else we got
um besides j.j sousavers which i'm sure
i'll pay to see
indeed i hope so 2027 i'll be a 57 year
old man will i still give a [ __ ] about
this [ __ ]
well it'll be on netflix you can watch
it two a.m stoned
done and done already my god [ __ ] i
need you around to
reassure me of all things that was
wonderful
um barry jenkins i know this name oh he
directed moonlight from the moonlights
yeah um both of them he directed both of
them both moonlights
um phil and teddy moonlight um
is directing the lion king too now is it
simba's pride
i don't know what the story is it better
be well
because he had a lot of it simmers pride
is about him having babies right
yes basically a 90-minute episode where
he's like yeah i feel the love tonight
[ __ ] i'm gonna put it right in your
circle of life we're gonna make a baby
how you doing nala
yeah that's the circle of life
so wait what uh he's doing a sequel is
this i guess
it needs a sequel because it made over a
billion dollars and they need to make
another billion dollars everything makes
everything if it makes
over a billion dollars it's going to get
a sequel and favreau is like
i'm too busy it's like i'm sorry i'm in
the volume man i'm doing a bunch of
[ __ ] mandalorians may i make a
request of barry jenkins
brilliant filmmaker he needs no advice
from me put some cartoon expressions on
these cats next time
yeah a little nobody gives a [ __ ] about
photo realism let's have him express
things let's have him be surprised let's
have him [ __ ] you know be like he he
he
let's have him nudge one another smart i
need at least six
cartoony emotions on these cats
six emotions no more than all i need
that'll tell a story
um i don't know if it's gonna be simba's
pride but according to deadline
um the story will further explore the
mythology of the characters including
mufasa's origin story
what moving the story forward while also
looking back
allah the godfather part two but said on
the african plane
oh it's the godfather part two of simba
movies uh yes
where it's what happens next and look
what happened to the other guys
howard we got here this is a mufasa
claiming [ __ ] pride rock in the first
place
look i'll take more james earl jones for
all times
yes and so faster although i bet you as
a young mufasa he'll have a different
voice
yeah it'll be vin diesel
family [ __ ] family
from like not in this one not in this
buoy i am groot wrong one wrong one
sorry sorry i am superman
[Laughter]
i am mufasa um all right
i didn't see the first one but i maybe
yeah you did
because you saw the 94 lion king and
it's mostly the same thing
hands up put that on a [ __ ] t-shirt
i did see the original lion king because
i saw it back in 1994 it's a long
t-shirt it is a bit but that's okay
type's cool look man if they if they
could make a [ __ ] flash grodden
t-shirt
did you see you got a shout out from a
t-shirt maker that was awesome
uh i feel like you know that that's
maybe better for a tick tock than a
t-shirt probably
but you know kids let me tell you kids
happy anniversary
happy anniversary i'm gonna go [ __ ] your
mother this [ __ ] is sly
it's a sly little liar you're a little
[ __ ] liar
aren't you 100 calories i'm so little i
can't hurt you
i'm making bad decisions right now
i haven't even left the building
all right what else we got what else we
got david s goyer
oh he's uh he's he's uh famous he's
written many things he has including
some batman
some supermans in the mans of steels
um he's had a few tv shows he has
indeeds
um he's doing a podcast he's doing a
batman podcast
you want to step to me goyer you don't
see me making blockbusters stay the
[ __ ] out of my backyard
[Laughter]
what's this podcast about uh it is a
scripted podcast oh all right that's
different
called batman unburied oh right now for
the audio streaming service
spotify for the spotifys i was talking
to them about doing dc podcasts
yeah and then i like many things in my
favor oh that'd be great and then i got
interested in my own [ __ ]
you know and you know who they got look
at david gordon instead
we don't need the likes of you silent
bill here's a guy that's actually worked
on batman
um good for him we can listen to this
thing it's going to be like the uh
neil gaiman the sandman podcast if i had
to get green podcasts like heavily
produced
um yeah not like badly i don't mean like
heavily produced no no heavily produced
meaning the sounds of gotham
not like how some people are heavily
made up and they don't look good like
oh throttle back well i just put a
little on first the 300th episode
thank you i was going to say you put no
makeup on so your cheeks look red
thank you very much good for goyer
he gets richer david goyer one of the
richest geeks in the world isn't he
indeed and you know what kids i'm not
taking anything away from david goyer's
talented man but you know where
david gore's superpower is he read a
bunch of things that he liked
and then he carried them into adulthood
and he makes grown-up versions of them
anybody can do that including you you
could be
david goyer oh boyer
never forget that next
they're like how come you ain't him then
i'm like well because i don't know
because i'd like not to be yeah i want
to be kevin smith i made the wrong
choice
why are we at the gas and sip at two
o'clock in the morning yeah choice man
a choice if you guys know so much about
girls why are you like here at a gas and
sip
like nine o'clock on a friday night
choice man
well done thank you it's a good movie
you're making me want to watch that
flick i haven't seen that in a while
there you go
i don't know if i can though honestly i
say that every time i leave here very
rarely i'd say
three out of ten times do i actually
watch the thing where i'm like oh i'm
going to watch that when i do it's
satisfying
yeah but sometimes i get home and i go
to like re-watch something i've watched
i don't know 100 times
and i'm like i can't do it again no
we live in a world of choice and it
always feels like there's something i
have to catch up on i still haven't
watched
um legion and they're done oh jamie gave
me the whole [ __ ] thing on blu-ray
and stuff i got no excuse not to watch
it and still
i you know what i just started watching
two weeks ago i am drunk because i'm
getting loud
i'm like hey hey you you're like i could
hear you hey neighbor you know what i'm
watching
hey um bojack horseman did you know
have you ever watched it i've never
watched it it's funny it's like and what
it more than it being funny it's
it's you know there's some funny stuff
in it but it's not like
they're literally making a [ __ ] show
like it's a show that you're engrossed
in we're like i hope this horse wants
happiness
it's it's you know and he's like it's
it's about people it's like really well
done and i hope this horse finds
it took me a while they're done they've
done six seasons they're finished and
i'm just jumping on the [ __ ] train
now and [ __ ] so you know what nice you
can ride with your own face
right at your own pace man that's true
let's do nine in a day [ __ ] do
nothing
remember there was a time you could see
it all remember there's a time you could
literally like i've watched all my shows
like i'm done these days are gone yeah
like my vhs my two vhs tapes that i use
to tape all the things i like
they're now empty ready for new [ __ ]
you'll never catch up again
you're always gonna be losing the race
to watch all the media there is to watch
and
some would argue that that's not losing
you're winning if you can't watch all
the entertainment made because that
means you're probably out there living a
life rather than watching fake people
live theirs
but i would argue that an interest in
fake people leading their lives has led
me to a real life where i write about
fake people leading their lives and then
talk about them on a podcast with this
guy
300 times in a row let's do it so
there's no right there's no wrong do
what feels good just don't do it in
public in front of people
unless you've got a napkin yeah there
you go or unless you've rented
out the whole theater unless you've got
a
napkin just saying you got to clean up
catch it
don't be an animal next
next that joke's sponsored by bud light
seltzer
this is brought to you by alcohol no
come joke too low for bud light seltzer
who else is uh making [ __ ] that we're
not this is always part of the show i
can't say because i'm like
boy everyone's busy except us how come
we're never in the news
well um remember we had one ms marvel
on the television uh just recently where
he's talking about his marvel herself
because she was in the video game the
avengers
absolutely and she was literally like
the only miss marvel in the world
now there's another one what the
reigning marvels
um wow uh a couple of ms marvels they're
making ms marvel for this tv show ms
marvel indeed for the next
her name is iman villani um she's
canadian yes look at her she's adorable
what'd you say she's watching she's
canadian
she's canadian girl she's a canadian
girl i support that
i know you do great country literally
the only reason i put in there because i
knew that you'd like that thank you but
big for those that are like why
should kevin smith from jersey give a
[ __ ] because uh i love canada i think
canada is an amazing country they get it
right
they're uh i'm not saying they're better
in america or anything like that you can
draw that conclusion for yourself but i
think they're a hell of a [ __ ]
country
and uh and the neighbor i respect and
admire and like to go hang out with
you know you grew up next to some people
i don't like my neighbors
i like my neighbors i so much so i want
to go up there and
recently and somebody's like you can't
and i was like what do you mean
like we'd have to quarantine for two
weeks and i was like all right well i'm
willing to do that
like you still can't go because you have
no reason to go like you're not a
diplomat
you're not [ __ ] a resident and all
that [ __ ] you're not shooting a
television show yet and i'm not shooting
a television show for the first time in
my [ __ ] 50 years
in this goddamn best of all possible
world somebody told me i couldn't go to
canada
who do we blame for this mark
well not this i'll tell you that much
this is taking me to canada right now
and i think you know a thing that that
i'm not sure if you've discovered this
yet about
uh kamala khan but she's going to be
played by a canadian
a character who's based in new jersey
that's true
oh my god why aren't i working on the
show you know
because you're not a little girl or a
woman yeah or you know
pakistani not true i don't have any of
the boxes checked on this one they're
like it'd be best if you just watched
this show like i got a beard wow
yeah well i got this and i'm ready to
watch this show i'm good for her and
good for the show i can't wait to
[ __ ] watch this [ __ ] look
more marvel tv shows and i say that only
having seen the one division trailer
so i'm they cannot [ __ ] that up that
[ __ ] looks brilliant and i think about
it all the time
because i think about how by the end of
it she's probably going to be like
mutants i'd like to not be alone
yeah oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] so cool
uh our last wife that trailer i was like
you got to watch this she's like what is
it i was like
you like her as an actress and he's a
great actor so you got to watch she said
what is it i was like is wanda vision
she goes i don't what is that i was like
well she played the scarlet witch she's
like i'm out i'm like do you [ __ ]
watch this
i made her watch it with me and she was
like that does look pretty good yeah
that's from somebody who's like not into
this [ __ ]
no no no from what i know of jen yeah
and he does know a lot
think about this think about me think
about how much i talk about this [ __ ]
yeah my wife doesn't like it do you know
how frustrating that is for me
that's why i come here and do it because
i can't do it at home i can't be like
oh my god do you know who they cast as
uh as kamala khan or kamala khan
and she's like the vice president needs
to be cast she's like i don't give a
flying
[ __ ] about your fantasy world
oh my god that's why i drink jam yeah i
was like then i'm gonna crack open
another one of these because she
understands
the [ __ ] about fantasy booze you get it
booze and weed hey hey baby how are you
doing she fills me up jen
you don't cheat us
it gives me confidence and energy
jennifer slams herself into our bedroom
and listens to the latest vin diesel
trackers
[Laughter]
i actually thought it was not bad but
they showed footage
of like i guess rachel ray's audience
and they were all video monitors
everyone's like
and then maybe it really turned me off
yeah it's like this is what you listen
to in the phantom zone like the shitty
part
like no i have to dance all right we'll
die
i gotta watch it without that footage i
think i might actually enjoy it but with
that footage i was like this is
unsettling
yeah is that how people enjoy music like
do you when you listen to music are you
ever like
can you just appreciate [ __ ] like just
doing this yeah or just a little like
you know
or this some of this there you go our
last story
is that last story of episode 300 ladies
and gentlemen [ __ ] grab your socks
and hoes and pull
you tease it up top did we well you
mentioned the flash movie
oh yeah we talked about it yes billy
crudup
is joining the flash movie again what
pre himself in indeed
i like crude up man dr manhattan og dr
manhattan the og dr manhattan
um he was attached to the flash four
years ago yeah as
barry allen himself and he's in justice
league right doesn't barry go to see him
in justice league and
he pops up is that justice league or is
it batman v superman
batman v superman i think yeah they're
all blur
pretty much one of the movies he met his
dad or he saw his dad
so now his dad's coming back now his
dad's coming back um
billy crudup's like uh hey everyone
likes this movie again i'm in
okay cool i'll come back because and
he's a snyder yeah a guy he was with him
on
watchmen he was with him on this
um but yeah so he's cut he's snyder cut
do you think he's snyder cut who billy
crudup yeah
couldn't even split it up billy billy
crudup yes
he's a really good actor man i did did
you see the morning show i never watched
the morning show
he was on that yeah him billy crudup
yeah i thought it wasn't him i thought
it was the
well steve carell is playing matt lauer
basically but yeah and then there was
another guy but i thought the guy was
one of those two brothers that's always
in one of the duplos brothers
yeah no there is a duploss brother but
there's also a billy credit crudip was
in it yeah
i think he passed the first episode you
no i didn't even start the first episode
but i hear it's good didn't get past the
first episode
not because it wasn't i wouldn't i
wouldn't say quote-unquote good but just
didn't grab me but if i'd known crudup
was in the deep dive crowd up comes in
long and strong i would have took off my
shirt got in there and did some
hearty [ __ ] because i like pulled up
[ __ ] yeah
i believe in billy cruz filled with
these still waters for crud i'm a golden
god
yeah i remember yes he was so he had
such a good heart in that movie
such a great performance i dig music
i dig music all right so he's back in
the flesh this flash movie
sounds like it's everything it's got all
the batman's
well almost i saw another report well i
don't know how true it is where people
were saying like uh
christian bale was like i might do it if
somebody stays out of my [ __ ] life
of ralph ford versus ferrari versus
batman
um i'm i'm i'm ready for this flash
movie i think it's the smartest thing in
the world they're doing is packing it
full of [ __ ] man
yeah and then rebooting their universe
they're they're not waiting for like
well maybe in three movies you'll want
to watch it
nope no way they're like [ __ ] let's
do you know honestly what they're doing
is like let's do what aquaman did
let's literally put nine movies into one
yeah think about it like you could have
got a whole movie out of [ __ ] black
manta
you got a whole movie out of ocean
master and these cats were like i don't
know we're ever going to get that chance
let's put everything but the kitchen
sink including a drum playing octopus
into this [ __ ] flick and they were
rewarded with a billion dollars
and they're making another one what does
that tell you kids put it all
in yeah just there's no such thing as
moderation
just do it all do it now not anymore
especially now are you kidding me what
the [ __ ]
is going to make people go back to movie
theaters that flash movie
that will make a [ __ ] go back to
movie theater like what 19
batman's 28 flashes and eight wonder
woman's [ __ ] them there
and a partridge in a whole pear tree
remember back in the day they were like
oh
these superhero sequels like they needed
a penguin
and a catwoman for batman 2. now they're
like we're putting in
every character ever invented in flash
one yes we're terrified people aren't
going to come see it i know it took
marvel 18 movies to get to 400
characters on the screen you're gonna do
it in one
yeah like we learned our lesson we're
not gonna do what we did last time so
here's a movie with a bunch of
characters
[ __ ] it let's do it live um but i'm on
board they'll get my money
god bless them all all right we're done
with questions we're done with news [ __ ]
that part of the show we're now just
drunk enough ladies and gentlemen to go
head-on with you
the home viewer jc howe here has been
the uh
chatter thus far uh chad's been good we
had a couple fun comments i'll share
or sweet comments i should say oh gary
smith
said gary smith my old man back
uh at the beginning of the show
he said it's not the commentary on other
people's news it's the relationship
between you two guys that's the draw oh
look at that yeah they like us they
really like us gary once yeah
sophia said when you get to a certain
age you're not a nerd you're a
connoisseur
with regards to you guys talking about
nerds
excellent point sophia we are uh where
they we curate the news here
we're sommeliers as mark sitter yeah
sophia merci bean
um all right this is everyone's favorite
part of the show
they love to ask questions and they love
to see us [ __ ]
dance over the fire like aunt harriet
we're doing 300 tonight right 300
questions 300 questions to celebrate our
300.
um three i believe is what we're doing
to celebrate 300 one for every 100
episodes
uh how many you got a question jason
i've got some questions
all right man hit us uh jc right there
you see him on the camera
proprietor this year establishment um
which as you could tell by the lack of
people in it has been affected by
[ __ ] covet and stuff like that and
yet
comes and opens up so we can do the show
here as we did
back when it was a normal [ __ ] world
man
he is laboring to make you feel like
everything's a-okay
and he's doing it without a mask put
your [ __ ] mask on
i like kindness of his heart he's good
dude give it up for jc the owner of this
place
all right jeff all right give us our
questions uh neil
is interested in knowing if you had to
choose three henchmen
to help you in your conquest of the
world who would you choose
now henchmen meaning like three randos
who i put matching sweatshirts on
or three super villains i think super
villains i mean henchman you'd just go
with like
villain number one from batman well
right away if you then you guys don't
know super villains because if i start
throwing around this henchman term to
king shark he's gonna be like what are
you [ __ ] nuts
i'm not a henchman i am the bad guy
you're a [ __ ] henchman so you got to
be careful i
say it if i'm picking you got to be
careful how you say it there's there a
lobby
like it's not super villains maybe it's
like bob from batman
who is not the actual like big boss but
like kind of
sexy basically yeah your number twos
your sidekicks
you go you lead uh i gotta i got three
to take over the world
um
watson um
cato nice excellent paul [ __ ]
and
tanto i don't i don't know if you're
answering the question as much as you're
looking for friends
you're like these are the people i wish
i was buddies with well i'm looking for
like a a
crazy smart war doctor i'm looking for a
tracker and i'm looking for a
a physical combatant ninja
all right i think i got i mean i could
probably also use like some cosmic level
power and i was gonna say how about
throwing magneto into that button yeah
but he's your he's your villain like you
need the the number two dude who's below
but still like all right then toad
because you know what happens to the
toad when lightning strikes
same thing that happens to everybody
give me give me wong
from doctor strange that was gonna be my
pick you can't pick nine
i was also going to pick wong because he
could whips up some magic he could do
some good magic [ __ ]
um let's see technically vader
is a sidekick excellent point he was in
star wars
just saying he's yours if you wanted it
i'll take him out i don't think darth
vader is my sidekick he's like what
what just like he didn't start
he'll have two reactions what and no
but still sidekick it is i'd be like
dude choke him from across the room he's
like i do a lot more than that [ __ ] you
[ __ ] click what else i was a little boy
and i was stolen from the desert
i was a slave boy who learned how to pod
race and i got to be big
my mom was killed by tuscan raiders so i
killed all of them
that's a dude you want on your side guy
who could go in and kill tuscan raider
children
uh you know who else i choose bellatrix
lacroix you know why
she killed dobby that's a hard-hearted
[ __ ] villain
you know how [ __ ] evil you gotta be
to stab dobby in a heart
that's metal i'll take her i feel like
your
your team is gonna outclass my team well
we're
certainly gonna be powerful and jaws no
he's the main character
has always wanted to be friends with him
but he's got limitations so i need
somebody
oh he's got to be water yeah he's not
good he's not a lion shark all right
look
lucifer is the lord of hell so you can't
take him correct
but you can take a lower lesser demon
right you're taking mazzakin or
my [ __ ] she's got half a face and [ __ ]
what kind of power she got have you seen
the show though she's hot in the show
come on i got a wife i'm not looking for
a hot i'm looking for
all conquering powers she's also
powerful but not half a face i say
beelzebub
lord of [ __ ] flies man he's on your
side number one look you see how many
flies it took for us to get past getting
this [ __ ] door
imagine if that guy had all the flies in
the world he could stop trafficking left
and right
there you go man darth vader [ __ ]
beelzebub
and bellatrix lacroix nice that's a good
team
not bad right i mean it's a bad team is
what it is i feel like your team kicks
my team's ass because i was going too
slow
too low in the front end we weren't we
weren't it wasn't a fight
but i survive and you die yes you're
dying next to wang
and [ __ ] going why didn't i choose the
lady who stabbed dobby
did you need me to bring you more
um that was a good question that wins a
prize oh nobody's here we're keeping the
prize
i think you need to add like salacious
crumb also just to keep it light
somewhat like a like look if we're
adding little sidekick animals and [ __ ]
i choose uh one of them shitty cats from
a disney cartoon they always got [ __ ]
puss on their face
the aristocats not one of the mean ones
man
one of the cats that are mean they're
like i'm gonna kill the [ __ ] goldfish
that are heroes of this [ __ ] whatever
[ __ ] it's one of the hyenas i'm lying
yeah a couple of them hyenas
the cheech and whoopi ones who was the
third one i don't remember
probably some british character actors
like hey i was oh he didn't say anything
he was like
like they talked and he did right he was
the silent bob and [ __ ] well like the
weasels from
roger rabbit would be good right holy
[ __ ] you know what i could do with an
army of them weasels and [ __ ]
but malaysia's chrome would keep making
them laugh and then they'd die
and salacious chrome didn't really add
anything other than like
i mean he tore threepio's eyes out yeah
that's true that's kind of psychotic too
like look at this [ __ ] thing that rat
creature's eating the [ __ ] robot's
eyes
i don't have a soul i'll take yours the
eyes are windows
god what an evil bastard you're right
yeah you could always whip him at the
[ __ ]
like cannon fodder throw him across the
room he lands on a [ __ ] and eats their
eyeballs like a
like a speed ball special like from
x-men like fastball
yeah special yeah ally oop
yeah speedball special was it john
belushi yeah i killed him
we don't want one of those um all right
next question john belushi did you see
the
trailer for the show time for the dock
no looking good
yeah yeah there's not enough belushi
stuff out there
no we're about to see a pretty good
looking dock it looks like all right
all right uh chelsea mills has been
paying attention chelsea
her question is who does kevin and mark
think would be a good doordash driver
from any comic universe wow
wow synergy um i give it to
kato and the black beauty okay he's
getting it anywhere man
can't do batman bla in the batmobile
because he'd be like i'm busy fighting
crime you think i'm really gonna [ __ ]
deliver food
but kato is like look we're not really
crime fighters we're super rich we got
to do that
what the [ __ ] else are we doing yeah
really when i'm not pretending to be a
criminal
i can pretend to deliver door dash no i
say kato and the black beauty
because ain't nothing get between you
and your [ __ ] food
cause they got missiles they got stinger
rays they got
sonics and [ __ ] like that plus it's
super fast they don't obey the [ __ ]
laws or cops
cato is your delivery driver for
doordash
go speed racer go speed racer go speed
racer go
oh my god the mach five mach five
delivering your food
get that [ __ ] off my track here's your
[ __ ] food
and if he's ever like like encounters a
little resistance [ __ ] racer x shows
up to clear his path
it's a team it's a doordash team speed
racer is sponsored by doordash
i like it it's a [ __ ] racing
endorsement we also would have accepted
ghost
rider he actually gets around a lot
quicker on a motorcycle
jim cummings the third hyena from the
lion king jim cummings was the third but
he didn't talk right he just giggled a
lot and [ __ ]
so winnie the pooh was the third boy is
that right winnie the pooh was the third
[ __ ] hyena
wow jim cummings does winnie the pooh
and tigger
and he did the third hyena ed oh
wow man we're learning some [ __ ] we're
learning some [ __ ]
i feel like goat's writing don't bother
same guy that did oh bother does
that guy it could be you now i know
because you just did them both
i wasn't fast enough your mind was very
stalled he does it fast
can't do it now i'm trying too hard i
feel like ghost rider would also ensure
that the food gets their hot
absolutely true just keep it above the
[ __ ] wheel yeah
i think we got this we did it thank you
excellent question
my pick would be peter parker from sam
raimi's spider-man 2
because we saw him deliver pizzas that's
true excellent point man peter parker
he's got a city to save though he can't
be delivering food totally and also like
can your pizza be reliably like coherent
when it arrives
peter parker's swinging through [ __ ]
town whipping it at your house it's
slamming from side to side yeah it's
just a big wad of [ __ ] cheese
[ __ ] the black beauty's got like one
of those boxes of hot boxes that it
sticks your food into
yeah it does i'll take it i'll tell you
whoever gets there i like jc's answer
too but
i think we nailed that one great
question thanks chelsea
all right that wasn't a chelsea that was
a chell ocean which is better a bigger
sea or an ocean uh oceans are bigger
cell ocean i say cello celosion
you gotta rub in that chill ocean thank
you uh final question of the evening
all right this is episode 300 all that's
standing between me and some veggie
grill
this is from uh i need because i'm
[ __ ] shit-faced
uh this is from shiloh's store shiloh
shiloh if kevin and mark had to make a
movie
from one of the ideas they've had during
the 300 episodes of the show
what would it be so every episode you
guys throw out great ideas
that jj abrams steals yeah what would
you guys do
mark's cinderella episode i thought was
so [ __ ] smart and original and [ __ ]
all right we'll do that in a heartbeat
let's do it dear netflix
we have a pitch for you listen to this
we gave it away
months ago on a podcast but i'm sure
nobody's doing it no
when that shows up we're suing
[Laughter]
for sure i i would have liked to have uh
i still would like to see the version of
rogue one that we had pitched
yeah what was that it was a better
version it was where
um it turns out that jyn erso was
the tie fighter pilot who spins out
darth vader
what right before vader goes what
yeah so that's the reason why she was
wearing the black suit in the trailers
that's that's the
the end of her run is if she's never
making another one which she isn't
anyway
right let's let her go out in style and
she was gonna [ __ ] shoot him
right but then [ __ ] han shows up and
blew her up and she's like she's blown
my spot i was gonna be the [ __ ] they
put
metal on my ass and instead she was
killed in a friendly fire incident
yes [ __ ] han solo war criminal i like
that
i forgot about it they never really talk
about that though right
like han swoops in and he shoots the tie
fighter
and by happenstance the other guy gets
flustered and knocks vader so
han isn't han missed like he hit greedo
but he missed when it comes to count the
shot
he didn't hit he got lucky and there's
no argument that he's like well i didn't
know which one vader was all tie
fighters look alike is like his looked
different yeah and you know that shoot
the one in the middle han
did you pay attention during the
briefing they're flanking him you
[ __ ] idiot like whatever it all
worked out but
give the dog the medal yeah you're all
clear kid let's blow this thing and go
home
oh we'll give the dog the medal 30 years
from now
yeah when the old when the other guy
dies as an afterthought we'll be like
here here's a medal yeah maybe those
crates that he's loading into the falcon
are coors
beer and not actually gold and he was
just
drunk off his skunk and he was like i
shot him he's galactically east bound
and down
indeed we gotta deliver this coors crush
first in atlanta um that answers that
question
i think so oh my god and we've done it
we've done it
300 episodes we've done 300 episodes in
the can
in the can well it sounds way sexier
than i mentioned blast them in the can
uh holy [ __ ] kids you're gonna get your
sunday back
you get to go and enjoy some time with
your family if you're on the east coast
you still got an hour before [ __ ] gets
late
if you're here on the west coast the
world is your oyster
i mean it's on fire and too hot yeah be
careful wear a mask and don't breathe
outside but the world is your oyster
did you have a good time ladies and
gentlemen we uh we
almost had guests reached james gunn
james gum was like any other week
i'd be there in a heartbeat so please
ask me again any other week that's
still saying no but this week any other
week i would not be into it this week
i'm really not into it
um i reached out to mark hamill and then
mark texted me
right before we went on the show and
then i was like that's too soon
and i was like you know what best way to
celebrate just you and me
go out like you went in yeah pretty
leave with the girl that brung you
and we're all drinking these so many of
them this was a good time
good time had by all good times man i
see you're still working the same
guinness well dude it's [ __ ] guinness
so it's like eating a cake it's like
this is chicken soup for the soul
and for the [ __ ] body and [ __ ] it's
just so thick
it's a loaf of beer you could open that
can and cut it like [ __ ] cranberry
sauce
oh come on son stop talking my love
language slicing cranberry sauce
i don't cotton for your like fancy
thanksgiving is coming i
made cranberry sauce [ __ ] you it's in a
can comes out a can you put it in slices
if it isn't ribbed for my pleasure then
i don't [ __ ] want to eat it
amen there it is that's what he says to
every dude
right before he puts on a condom they
ripped for my pleasure i need it
nope my favorite thing this weekend
they'll tell me was a couple days back
george
george takei american treasure yes
himself
went on the internet and said you know
what would be great
tick-tock kids and bts fans and k-pop
stands
is if we went on twitter and tweeted out
pictures
of men kissing men of of of the gayest
things you can imagine
and hashtag it proud boys no
so that every time you click on the
prideboys hashtag you will just see
nothing but glorious pictures of men in
love with each other
proudly it worked did it really this
weekend was proud boys weekend
and it was the most wonderful thing on
the internet a lot of [ __ ] like
it was just so much love just like you
know that the
two dudes recreating that world war ii
v-day kiss in the middle of times square
and pride parades and rainbows and
unicorns and
platform shoes and boas there's hope yet
there's love out there in the world as
long as your sulu lives
there's always just always hope wrap
that dude and [ __ ] bubble wrap and
don't let anything happen to him he's a
treasure
those are you we treasure you folks
ladies and gentlemen
uh thank you for hanging out with us
here thank you for trending proud boys
as a bunch of
pictures of gay dudes i'm gonna go home
look at it right now and jerk off
thanks thanks for that information mark
thanks and if my wife walks in she's
like what are you doing i'm like i'm
looking at nazis
yes i'm a proud boy too but in reality
i'm like look at these hot brown boys
oh my god these proud boys are getting
off on each other this is tremendous
um thank you ladies and gentlemen for
being here 300 [ __ ] episodes
300 more to go another 300 after that
and then when we're dead and gone
someone will be standing here
doing it for us rebooting it yes over
and over and over again
um there would be no 300 of anything
were it not for the guy standing uh to
the left
of me give it up for mr mark bernard
thank you mr smith too kind and sad oh
you know what we also wouldn't have a
show without
the dude in the back who you never get
to see give it up for andrew ladies and
gentlemen
give it up for the guy who owns this
here establishment right there you
always get to see him
give it up for jc yeah later give it up
for jordan who always makes the show
happen
jordan at home always makes this happen
tells us when to go what to do
pays bills and stuff like that thank you
for making this possibility thank you
particularly to the audience who shows
up and watches this show
otherwise we'd have no point in doing it
and stuff and thank you to you
for inviting me on this crazy madcap
ride with you my friend why thank you
for accepting my friend
we get to do this every week talk about
cool [ __ ]
oh put it on the glass you have been
and shall always be my friend remember
the [ __ ] point in the movie where
he's like
there it is ladies and gentlemen batman
beyond the wrath of khan
thanks for being here for fat man beyond
i'm kevin smith
mark bernardin tune in next time same
that time
same fat channels modcast.com or
ship out of danger
part of star trek ii get a scene it
shouldn't be funny at all
youtube.com kevin smith goodbye
goodbye peace out